We're asked to graph the
function f of x is equal
to the principal square
root of 0.5x minus 1.
And to graph it,
we're just going
to sample some points,
some x values that
are within the domain of
this function definition.
And see what the function is
equal to for those x values.
And then we could
connect the dots
and see what the
curve might look like.
So let me do a
little table here.
And so I'm going to
pick some x values.
And I'm going to figure out
what the f of x values are,
given those x values.
Actually, I'm going
to do something
in between because I want
to have nice, clean numbers.
I want to pick x values that
are nice, clean integers.
And I want to get f of x values
that are nice, clean integers.
So I'm going to be a little
bit more careful in what
x values I pick.
I want to pick x values so that
this part of the expression,
this part of the
function definition,
ends up being an integer.
And if this needs
to be an integer,
then what's underneath
the radical, 0.5x,
that needs to be
a perfect square.
So actually, let me make
another column right over here
just to make our math
a little bit cleaner.
You could pick just
arbitrary x points.
You could pick x to be 1,
2, 3, just go like that.
But on some of those, you
might get strange radicals
over here, which
would be hard for us
to graph without a calculator.
So let's try.
So let me write over
here what 0.5x is,
and I'm doing this just
so I can pick this.
We want this thing right over
here to be perfect squares
because if 0.5x is
a perfect square,
then the square root of that
is going to be an integer.
So let's say that 0.5--
let's think about all
of the perfect squares.
Well, we could start with 0.
Then, we could go to 1.
Then, we could go to-- Let's
see, 2 is in a perfect square,
3 is in a perfect square.
I'm just thinking
of all the values
that if I took the square
root, I get an integer.
And then I go to 4.
Then, I go to 9.
Then, I go to 16.
Then, I go to 25.
These are definitely the
first five perfect squares.
And, obviously, 0 you take the
principal square root of that,
you get 0.
So these would be
good values for 0.5x.
But if those are what 0.5x
is equal to, what is x going
to be?
So if 0.5x is 0, then x
is also going to be 0.
You could solve it separately
in an equation right over here.
You could say 0.5x
is equal to 0.
x is equal to 0 divided by 0.5.
Just divide both sides by 0.5,
and you get that equal to 0.
So in general, to get
what the x value is,
we just have to take this
number and divide it by 0.5.
Or, another way to think
about it, take this number
and multiply it by 2.
So when 0.5x is 1,
that means x is 2.
0.5 time 2 is 1.
0.5 times 8 is 4.
0.5 times 18 is 9.
0.5 times 32 is 16.
0.5 times 50 is 25.
So these are the x's
we're going to pick.
And, once again, I
picked them just so
that this part of the
expression, this part
of the function definition,
comes out cleanly.
And now let's figure out what
f of x is at those values.
So f of 0 is going to be equal
to the square root of 0.5
times 0.
Let me make my radical
a little bit bigger.
0.5 times 0 minus 1.
Well, this part right
over here is just 0.
0 minus 1 is just going
to be equal to negative 1.
Now let's try it
when x is equal to 2.
f of 2 is going to be equal to
the square root of 0.5 times 2
minus 1.
We already know that this part
right over here is equal to 1.
So you have 1 minus
1 is equal to 0.
Now let's do the next one.
f of 4-- I've already
used that blue color.
I'll use green.
f of 4 is equal to
0.5 times 4 minus 1.
So this is we already
know-- Oh, sorry.
0.5 times 8.
We're not taking f of 4.
We're taking f of 8.
Let me be careful.
This is what the x values are.
So f of 8 is equal to
0.5 times 8 minus 1.
This part right over
here we'll evaluate too.
So 0.5 times 8 is 4.
You take the square root,
the principal root of 4.
You get 2.
2 minus 1 is equal to 1.
Then over here, we'd
want to do this in pink.
f of 18 is square root
of 0.5 times 18 minus 1.
0.5 times 18 is 9.
You take the square
root of that.
You get 3.
3 minus 1 is equal to 2.
We'll do a couple more.
f of 32 is equal to
0.5 times 32 minus 1.
So it's the square
root of 16 minus 1.
So that's 4 minus 1.
The principal root of
16, which is 4 minus 1,
which is equal to 3.
And then, finally,
do one more of these.
f of 50 is equal to the
square root of 0.5 times 50.
0.5 times 50 is
this 25, and we're
going to take the square root.
So this whole thing is
going to evaluate to 5.
5 minus 1 is equal to 4.
So we've taken some
x's is in our domain.
And it's very important
to realize here
that our domain is restricted.
It is not all real numbers.
And the reason why
it is restricted
is if we're going to
take the principal root,
right-- for the
sake of this if we
don't go into things
like imaginary numbers.
And don't worry about that if
you don't know what those are.
We have to assume that what's
underneath the radical sign
is positive.
And in order for that to be
positive x has to be positive.
So in order for 0.5x to be
greater than or equal to 0,
which is what the principal
root is defined over,
for our purposes in this video,
then if you divide both sides
of this inequality by 0.5,
you say that x has got to be
greater than or equal to 0.
So we sampled some
points in the domain.
The domain is all
real numbers, all
x's or all real numbers
greater than or equal to 0.
We sampled some points there.
We've strategically
picked them so that we'd
get nice, clean
answers for f of x.
But now that we
figured out what f of x
is at each of these points,
we're ready to plot.
So let me draw some axes here.
So that's our x-axis.
And let's make this our y-axis.
And I'll say y is
equal to f of x.
So whatever f of x
we get for a given x,
we're going to set that
equal to y and plot it
on the vertical axis.
This is our x-axis
right over there.
And let's go point by point.
Well, actually, first
let me draw the scale.
So the x-axis goes
all the way to 50.
So let me divide this.
So let's say that this is 10.
This is 20.
This is 30.
This is 40.
And this is 50.
And then our y-axis,
we're going to have
to go between negative 1 and 4.
So let's make this negative 1.
Let's make that 1, 2, 3, and 4.
And now we're ready to
plot all the points.
So when x is equal to 0, y,
or f of x, is negative 1.
So you have the
point 0, negative 1.
0, which is right over
there, 0, negative 1.
So let me actually-- this
right over here is 0.
But we want to plot the
point, 0, negative 1
is going to sit
right over there.
Let me give its coordinates
that is 0, negative 1.
Then, we plot 2 comma 0.
So 2 is going to be right
around-- So that is 5.
2 is going to be
right around there.
2 comma 0 is going
to be right there.
So that point right over
there is 2 comma 0 in magenta.
Now we go to 8.
Let me switch to that
same green color.
We go to 8 comma 1.
8 is going to be
right around here.
We go 1 in the
vertical direction,
gets us right about there.
That is the point 8 comma 1.
Then, we go, in this pink
color, to 18 comma 2.
When x is 18, f of x is 2.
When x is 18-- 18 gets
us right about there.
When x is 18, f of
x is equal to 2.
So that puts us
right about there.
So that is 18 comma 2.
Then, what's our next color?
We'll use orange then.
Then, we have 32 comma
3 where f of 32 is 3.
So 32 is right about there.
And f of 32 is 3.
So it gets us
right, right there.
So that is the
point, 32 comma 3.
And then we have the last sample
of our domain, which is x is 50
and f of 50 is 4. x is 50.
f of 50 is 4.
So I'll put it right over there.
So this is the point 50 comma 4.
And now, we can
connect the dots to get
the graph of the function.
I'll do that in white.
So if I connect the
dots, I get a curve
that looks like half
of a sideways parabola.
And that's essentially
what it is.
So my curve will look
something like this.
It's important to realize
that the graph of the function
isn't just these point.
It's actually any
of these points.
If I were to pick an
arbitrary x values in domain--
remember the x
values, the domain
here is x is greater than or
equal to 0, or any real number
greater than or equal to 0.
So if I pick anything
on the x-axis that
is greater than or equal
to 0 that's in the domain,
and then if I
evaluated its function,
it should sit on that curve.
It should sit on that
curve that I just drew.